yeah like that's
it's funny i've like rejected guys
because i felt like they were too
good-looking
really yes
tell us the psychology behind that well
i'm like okay i'm really out of my
league no like that like i swear to god
you're like you're too hot no it was
funny because i found out this guy
wanted to date me later but i like i
figured he was just trying to sleep with
me because i was like what are you like
i just felt like he was out of my league
like
you're looking at me
yeah
no i swear to god because he was like
like really really like attractive and i
was like of course he just wants to
sleep with me but then i found out later
that he wanted to date me i was like oh
oh well
yeah that's going to decide i messed up
there pearl yeah i know i
i fumbled the bag but i'm like
i don't know i don't think i'm the i
think most girls don't really understand
the difference to be honest yeah because
because they like the attention from a
man anyways what you're saying
so they don't understand whether it's
sexual or
well it's kind of like when i talk to
girls and i'll see the guys
they reject and i'm like they're all
better looking than you
like i think this all the time
yeah um why do you think
that
uh
do you think it's always been like that
like women have always rejected guys who
you would say objectively were as
good-looking than them or no i think i
think birth control changed everything
because before okay before
if i slept with a guy like i had to
think about could i get pregnant right
and so
you know i think people were a little
bit more careful back then but you you
add birth control to the game it takes
away the consequence yeah so for
everyone right because guys would
probably think about it too they don't
want to knock up you know
ugly
so that gives like a smaller percentage
of guys access to like more women it's
very true yeah yeah it's very true i
mean this that day in app social media
like yeah we live in a
you know globalized dating market yeah
you can think of someone from paris from
luda from dubai
so it just kind of it's left a lot of
men displaced i think i forget you you
coach women like do you like do
one-on-one sessions yeah i do yeah so
what are the biggest complaints you hear
the biggest complaints yeah from women
um usually
usually why why do guys avoid commitment
or the why do the guys they deal with
yeah why why are they avoiding
commitment from them basically
what would you say the reason that that
is
uh well i usually see how they dated the
guy and i'll be like okay well if you
started sleeping with him from day one
yeah you put yourself in the friends for
benefit zone which is kind of like the
friend zone yeah for guys it's
near impossible to get out of unless you
kind of distance distance yourself from
her or have some dramatic transformation
um
but also like
if we're just going to keep it a stack
the kind of guys that you know
they're dealing with you know are the
guys who have options
do what i mean and if a guy has options
sexual options and if he's not looking
like you said to build a legacy or
settle down
then he's going to play around it's like
well
he probably has a rota maybe three or
four different women right if one woman
is just like hey if you don't commit to
me today i'm leaving he's like bye
don't you think it's the woman's fault
then that what that for not even
realizing that in the first place
because if you know that he's got this
this rotation or if you even have a
feeling yeah then
you didn't go there with the right
foundation i think um i think it's both
i think
i'll be honest i think a lot of women
modern women today
uh they don't know how to date in a way
that leads to a relationship
um
because i think they've been told to act
like men which doesn't help them get
commitment a lot of do you think they
want a relationship
i think i think most yeah i think most
do i think you can go through phases
like you just want to have fun but i
think most most women definitely do want
to have a relationship i think if
a lot not all but if a lot of women are
honest with themselves they know they're
not wife material anyway
are you i don't think i'll be honest i
don't think
a lot of women think that
you don't think older women think that i
don't think a lot of i don't think a lot
of women look at themselves because
we're lied to all the time
like constantly yeah
no girls are
because
your girlfriend so you know
they will see you do you failed
relationship after failed relationship
after
we're like no you just you deserve it
like you're doing great and it's like
you know what she's doing is not great
no that's like you know what your
girlfriend is doing is not great it's
not leading to that man yeah what she's
doing is putting herself in a certain
bracket anyway and then expecting to be
all of a sudden be someone's wife well
and i also don't think girls really date
to get married that's very true yeah
they date for a relationship right which
that's why that's what i remember do you
date do you think they really want it
because it's not really that's what i
mean by do you think they really want it
because it's not really um
in terms of long term yeah because if
you're gonna go to date someone what is
it
for
but then don't you think dating is
changing now
like i just think
the relationships between men and women
are actually changing i think um
i don't think i was saying this on um
you know these emails yeah right i was
on her show and i was saying this on her
show and i said it to her i said i think
the model that we're working with yeah
ain't working
because the statistics are showing that
it's not working i think yeah i go no no
i agree with you know i'm just not
saying it's actually not working so
the next question becomes okay cool so
we're having all these failed
relationships both men and women yeah
what's the next step and i think the
next step is honesty
and you know what i mean and i think
we're just not honest like i said i said
when i was speaking to i said
a guy knows
whether or not he's going to be
monogamous or not before he even gets
with you he knows himself yeah whether
he's going to cheat
potentially
because women have been sold the dream
of monogamy but but sorry sorry so so if
you've been sold the dream of monogamy
right yeah
he knows
he likes you
all right cool yeah yeah monogamous baby
yeah i love you too
and he knows people sign whole marriage
contracts knowing they're gonna cheat on
their wife
that dude
but some i think some guys
i think
but you know if you're a cheater or not
you know that can can your can you
switch every individual is capable of
cheating every individual yeah i know
that but
if you know yourself and you know you're
the type of man or woman that your eyes
can stray right and yeah you might
yeah wouldn't you just be honest no
jolly
okay and say because they want because
they feel like they found the man or
they found the woman they're not gonna
tell the truth i think girls i think
guys are more upfront than girls give
them credit for we just don't listen yes
so guys will say i'm not looking for
something serious and girls will take
that ass let me sleep with him till he
changes his mind
we're talking about two different films
because some guys actually really just
ain't honest and then that's true some
girls really
don't listen
that is true there's both of the
dynamic that happens that's true you
know that's true there and i've always
said to people be honest because when
you're honest you'll get your best
outcome you know it might take a while
but if i say to a woman you know what
you know babe i love you you know but or
where to date number like you know what
type of guy you do you know what type of
guy that i may want like two women or
maybe three oh oh my god no all right
peace not you
yeah but there'll be a woman that'll be
like hmm
okay yeah but don't you think someone
lets her just hold on to girls just
because they can like because you you
know you know how you said peace not you
don't some man will be like hmm stay
here until i find the next one then
then i'll let you monkey branches yeah
you know what i'm saying now that's true
i think both men and women do that as a
matter of fact i think there are women
out there like i don't know what
statistic was i it was on the view
actually the women were talking about it
and they were saying um
that a lot of women
have like a reserve guy
of course come on like just think a
backup guy like just in case
i saw this stat men do too though men do
too yeah no the stat was on both ends it
was like
it was women i don't remember off the
top of my head i'm going to butcher it
but i know women it was more but like
still a decent percentage of men do too
but the thing is
and that's the thing why not just be
honest
well because why not say i want both of
those
i want both of you i want both of you
babies okay have you do you do you feel
like you're not monogamous
i feel like i can be monogamous my last
relationship was ten years okay i was
together with a woman for ten years i
was monogamous throughout the
relationship okay right so i know i can
be okay what i'm doing now honestly
is looking at the landscape because i'm
now single i'm like
is it is it
do i want to go back into one a
monogamous relationship or do i want to
try something different okay i just
wanted to know if you've ever said that
to a girl and how she reacts 100 i've
said it to a girl okay what'd she say to
all the girls that i meet okay
really but like
as actors as artists
uh especially in my industry people are
more open-minded okay yeah because
that's myself yeah i can see that
especially in musical theater because
that's what i do so
yeah they can be a bit more not
everyone's like that but they can be
more open to it
okay so how
did any of them react poorly and just
say they could never do that yeah um
i don't they're like i don't share yeah
women have said that
they've said i don't so are you guys
both trying to set up like
like would it be like a three-way
relationship or would it be like
like that
yeah yeah like is it is it like uh
is it like the two girls with the one
guy you know and then they become like
sister girlfriends or whatever this is
the sister
sister
or is it more like
like okay you're my you're my girl
and i will
i'm basically going to go to the streets
and like f these girls i don't care
about but don't worry they're just like
hoes
okay